welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and we got to talk
about the new sneak peek of black adam
from san diego comic-con today i'm
taking you frame by frame to break down
all the new details you might have
missed in the most recent teaser trailer
the teaser opens with black adams back
to us as he hovers in the glow of an
explosion although we don't see him from
the front in this initial image his
hooded cloak appears to be drawn from
his caped look in 2011's justice league
vol 2 comics we do however see the full
view of him wearing it later on in the
trailer as he faces down two helicopters
in the sky fun fact if you take a shot
every time there's a helicopter crash in
a dc movie you will die of alcohol
poisoning about halfway through suicide
squad
next we see terrified bystanders running
through the streets this scene takes
place in sheruda the capital of the
fictional country kondok where black
adam rules like a god in the new 52
comics confirming this we can see a bus
with the word shiruta metro emblazoned
on its side when adam smasher almost
gets blown up towards the end of the
trailer the primary language spoken in
kondok is arabic and culturally the
country is most similar to egypt black
adam flies through the city shooting
lightning from his hands just like
shazam his heroic counterpart who shares
the same powers strengths and abilities
in shazam's very first appearance in
1945's the marvel family issue number
one the wizard explains that he created
black adam before captain marvel aka
shazam in hopes that he would be the
hero to rid the world of evil as for
black adam's origin story in the dceu
we've already seen a sneak peek of it
when billy batson steps off the subway
and into the rock of eternity in shazam
the wizard explains that he's standing
at the source of all magic where seven
wizards once resided their council
recklessly chose a champion who
ultimately used the powers they gave him
for revenge and that champ was none
other than black adam who went on to
free the seven deadly sins based on this
light show and the clips we've seen it's
looking like dceu's black adam was
inspired by black adam's new 52 origin
story that debuted in 2011's justice
league volume 2 run in the comics adam
and his nephew aman were slaves in
kondok thousands of years ago after the
rest of their family is murdered by
dictators the wizard blesses both adam
and aman with his powers hoping that
these two new champions use them to save
kondok with his heartful of revenge adam
kills his nephew steals his power and
rules over conduct with an iron fist
he's imprisoned by the wizard for his
betrayal and awoken 5 000 years later
swearing vengeance on shazam from dc's
2021 fandom teaser we know that this
movie will show black adam duking it out
with the wizard before being sealed away
in ruins within conduct side quest while
we're talking about that fandom teaser
the opening image of kondok is pulled
directly from 2016's 52 issue number one
those statues looked so cool in the
comics and i'm stoked that we get to see
this view recreated for the big screen
from another previous trailer we learned
that adam's son sacrificed his life to
save his father here in the teaser we
see his son raise his arms in an
offering before being killed while adam
watches powerless to save him this
reminds me of 1999's justice society of
america number 43 and 44 in which black
adam reveals to shazam that his wife and
son were killed in conduct by the
powerful priest octon driving him to
seek revenge i predict that this movie
will expand on the premises introduced
in both justice league volume 2 and just
as society of america showing the pain
suffering and desire for vengeance that
drove black adam in the aftermath of his
family's deaths black adam's voiceover
tells us that his powers are not a gift
but a curse born out of rage black adam
likely views his abilities in this light
because his near immortal status
prevents him from dying and finding
peace from his survivor's guilt next we
see a brand new look at black adam's
suit lit up by streams of lightning
illuminating his eyes radiating from the
bolt on his chest and making him look
badass as i'll get out again i got a
throw to this image from 2011's justice
league vol 2 issue 10 and 2013 shazam it
was clearly the inspiration for this
exact moment down to the glowing eyes
now is it just me or does the blue
energy of this look like the rpg missile
from the first trailer if you look
closely at the rocket the rock is rocket
blocking there's a glowing blue light
inside the chamber when it explodes it
emits a light blue wave of smoky light
that looks like a smaller version of
this gigantic explosion in this teaser
this tells me that the teaser's
explosion was likely set off by the
organization sent to free black adam the
antagonistic inter-gang in the comics
intergang is an organized crime
syndicate supplied with weapons from the
evil new gods of apocalypse seeing the
power level of their current weaponry
makes me wonder if they've already been
messing with otherworldly tech possibly
repurposing an assortment of scavenged
resources from previous dceu entries
this explains how they could have the
hoverbikes seen later in the trailer as
well i love dr fate's intro in this
teaser he phases into the room in static
golden light that dissipates as he
removes the helmet of fate it's pierce
brosnan you gotta take off the helmet
and look at that gorgeous face according
to the comics the helmet of fate is one
of the most powerful artifacts in the dc
universe and grants the user a butt ton
of powers like spell casting healing
flight and elemental manipulation to
name a few as he touches the top of it
later on a red zap of light appears
beneath his hand seemingly
telepathically alerting him to some sort
of cosmic disturbance possibly the
awakening of black adam when we see fate
fight black adam later on in the trailer
he uses a sorcery to create several
copies of himself just like his marvel
counterpart dr strange the cloak he's
wearing is the cloak of destiny an
artifact that's resistant to both fire
and magic he presents black adam with
two choices he can either save the world
or destroy it but as an anti-hero this
dude doesn't operate in black and white
good and evil he's not a hero or a
villain he's black adam still we've got
to acknowledge that the justice society
of america's talent scouts are seeking
to put ba on a redemption arc the next
time we see dr fate and the teaser
notice the jet flying overhead this is
the justice society of america's steel
eagle aka the personal aircraft flown by
the jsa a few moments later a maskless
atom smasher played by noah centineo
sits inside with fate and hawkman just
before the jet crashes into the side of
a building in conduct causing an
explosion that destroys an open-air
market next we see the swirling blend of
red hair and green robes that is cyclone
lead by quintesses swindell who uses her
wind manipulation powers to throw a
bunch of pipes at black adam to capture
him just like in the comics her
character will be a part of the jsa in
the film then we see adriana tomez
played by actor sarah shai who said in
an interview that her character is quote
a freedom fighter that's leading this
big resistance against an evil malicious
group called intergang in the comics
intergang kidnaps adriana and gives her
as a gift to black adam who thankfully
is like bro women aren't gifts adam
bestows upon her the amulet of a seat
and she's imbued with the powers of
superhuman speed and durability light
healing elemental manipulation and
telekinesis when hawkman played by
aldous hodge leaps skyward wings
unfurled you can see a kfc in the
background here it stands for kendaki
fried chicken finger licking good
embarrassingly for hawkman his
thanagarian mace and low wingies are no
match for black adam's lightning that
mace is made out of the same material
that gives hawkman his powers nth metal
an alien metal that negates gravity you
know black adam is strong if he can just
grab onto that thing like a baby rattle
with all of the uncertainties and
variables floating around in the dceu my
hope is that black adam will help to
revitalize these movies steering them in
a direction that us fans will appreciate
it's like dwayne johnson himself once
said the rock is basically franchise
viagra
franchise viagra so if anyone can catch
dc fans attention with black adam it's
this guy follow me on instagram and
twitter whitneypuppy follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you